the 2020 Grammy nominees were announced
on Wednesday morning and the list is
full of snubs and surprises first up
Halsey I met myself thought you know if
I'm doing well and the people I love are
happy and taken care of and everything
is good the singer has yet to be
nominated in a big four Grammy category
record of the year album of the year
song of the Year and Best New Artist
[Music]
this year she had her first number-one
smash with without me but still got no
Grammy love next up Bona ver the band's
I I al b'm wasn't a chart buster but the
nominations review committee was clearly
all about it the album was nominated for
album of the year and Hema was nominated
for record of the year Sam Smith's hit
collab with normani dancing with a
stranger was overlooked this year the
singer won four Grammys five years ago
but hasn't been nominated since
meanwhile her received five nominations
this year the same number of noms she
had last year
damn girl way to go the 22 year old is
nominated for record album and song of
the year a big Grammy snub this year
goes to Maren Morris the country singer
was a top nominee at this year's CMA
Awards with six nods I feel like being
in the pop and the dance and the country
categories it's like what a year what a
weird year but she was almost shut out
of the Grammys altogether her only
nomination is for best country duo/group
Performance for common featuring Brandi
Carlile Maren one album of the Year at
the CMAs but was passed over for both
album of the year and best country album
surprise Michelle Obama is nominated for
Best spoken word album for becoming if
she wins she will be the second first
lady or former first lady to win in that
category Hillary Rodham Clinton won in
1996 when her husband Bill was in office
for it takes a village
[Applause]
Taylor Swift's lover wasn't exactly
loved by the Grammy nomination committee
[Music]
this is the first time that the pop star
has missed out on an album of the Year
nomination but the title track was
nominated for song of the year so
there's that it's really special
while the Jonas Brothers were nominated
for Best Pop duo/group Performance for
sucker they didn't get any other big
nominations moving on some surprises in
the number of nominations other artists
got like Liz o who's nominated for eight
awards this year I mean it feels really
good I've been working my ass off for a
long time everybody knows the people who
know no lil nas ex received six Grammy
nominee Eilish I could have bet you
money that that wouldn't ever happen
I never in a million years what about
this happens like I'm only grateful for
it
for real the 2020 Grammys will air in
January and you better believe et will
be here to break down all the biggest
losses and wins so make sure to keep it
locked right here I'm Hallie Stevens see
you next time
[Music]